cette annonce on la trouve sur éclats le
nouvel espace numérique de travail
initié par la région et le rectorat
dans une lettre ouverte à françois
sauvadet l'opposition départementale
estime que cet espace a été détourné de
son véritable objet on est passé par le
biais de nt l'espace numérique de
travail qui est à une plateforme
numérique dédié aux collégiens mais qui
est une plate forme pour que l'éducation
nationale l'académie puisse j'allais
dire communiquer avec la famille et les
collégiens
cet espace est toutefois ouvert aux
partenaires de l'éducation nationale
dont les collectivités territoriales
mais il se trouve que leurs modalités
d'intervention sur le site sont encore
en discussion au rectorat l'initiative
de françois sauvadet donc jugé un peu
intempestives voire choquantes autres
critiques de l'opposition
le vendredi après midi les collégiens ne
sont pas censés écouter le président du
conseil départemental mais leurs
professeurs sur ce point la paix en côte
d'or fédérations de parents d'élèves et
plus conciliant ce qui reste à poser
comme question c'est la pertinence de
tous ces événements et de cet événement
là mais en l'occurrence si les
établissements font le chemin de laisser
sortir les élèves c'est quelque part
derrière il ya quand même un fond
d'intérêts pour eux mais les principaux
de collèges ont-ils les coudées franches
sachant que le conseil départemental
financent leurs investissements selon
l'opposition il aurait été très
sollicité sur cet événement des
principaux nous ont alertés sur le fait
qu' il était sollicité par les services
du département pour pouvoir entre
guillemets envoyé nombre de collégiens à
cette manifestation
françois sauvadet n'a pas souhaité
répondre à nos questions par communiqué
il indique qu'il ne veut pas polémiquer
par respect écrit-il pour ces milliers
de jeunes qui ont débattu de leur avenir
en côte d'or dans chaque collège fin de
citation